So, uh, first exercise.
Um, anybody been to Panera before? So, I
I love Panera. I got these little kids.
They can make a mess and it's like kind
of acceptable. Um, we try to clean up,
but uh,
so Panera, one of the main focuses of
their menu is that you pick two. So,
that's what we're going to do. You get
to pick two. There's a bunch of cards on
the center of your table. And in a
minute, what I'm going to ask you to do
is pick two. You can spread out the deck
so you can actually look and and shop
for the words. Pick two words that if
combined well could transform your year.
So pick two words that if combined and
the combination is important because if
you just get soup, you miss out on the
salad. And so by picking two words,
sometimes chocolate is good and
sometimes peanut butter is good, but you
give me a Reese's and I'm like, "Yes,
give me more of that." All right. And so
pick two words that you feel like if
combined
could transform the rest of your year.
So pick them and then once you've got
them, uh, share it with just one other
person uh, right next to you. All right,
go for it.
[Music]
Once you got two, you don't have to uh
wait for me. I know. I know. We're all
suited up. I have to say, um, you all
look sharper than the CIA. The series of
sessions with the CIA, and I'm looking
at you, you're taking a group picture
out there. I'm like, dang, you're not
looking serious. Um, so just because we
have uh jackets on right now, um, really
inviting levity. So there's not like
you're not going to break rules. you're
not going to screw up video footage,
anything like that. Like, uh, and so, in
other words, you don't need to wait for
all my cues. So, uh, feel free if you
got two cards just with the one other
person because you're kind of splitting
your table in half. Um, share your
thought process behind that combination.
[Music]
[Applause]
All right. What are you gonna do
tomorrow?
Hey, very good. Exactly. So, uh,
depending on how I'm feeling, sometimes
I I'll get on an airplane and when
somebody turns to me and asks me, "Hey,
uh, what do you do?" First of all, I'm
like, "You don't even know what landmine
you just stepped on." Um, but depending
on how I'm feeling, I'll say, "Well,
half my job is starting conversations
and the other half is ending them." Um,
and I don't I don't really say that too
often, but I'm glad you really
appreciated that. So, I'm saying that to
you now, um, just because because we're
filming lots of different exercises. If
we had, uh, more laxed time, I I
probably wouldn't interrupt quite as
quickly, but for the sake of time, um,
I'm going to be stopping a lot of
conversations perhaps before their time
is due. Um, and let that just be an
invitation to continue it over lunch,
during breaks, the rest of the time that
you, uh, spend with each other. And the
the idea here is um really that the
conversations we start here become
little uh anchors and seeds to start
future conversations. Um what happens is
when we have dialogues and connections
like this with people, when you pass
someone in the hallway or you see a
client at a grocery store or whatever
else, if you have some of this personal
uh information, some of knowledge of who
they are, it's much more easy and you're
much more likely to stop and say, "Hey,
how is the blank?" Right? in your roles,
uh, you get all up in somebody's life.
Um, and so you have a lot of those
details.